a un día histórico en eeuu y aquí en la
corte suprema de justicia ya empiezan a
llegar
simpatizantes de esta decisión de la
corte suprema de justicia y también
gente que se opone a esta decisión usted
lo decía no toma por completo por
completa sorpresa al país porque ya se
ha filtrado este documento de la opinión
de la mayoría conservadora de la corte
suprema de justicia que anunciaba la d
contra wait samuel alito uno de los
magistrados más conservadores de eeuu
dijo lo siguiente en la opinión dijo que
la constitución no confiere el derecho
al aborto y que por ende esta autoridad
de el aborto tiene que regularse por
parte de los estados y de los
representantes electos es decir que a
partir de ahora son los estados son los
50 estados en eeuu los que definirán las
restricciones la legislación en cuanto
al aborto esto después de 50 años cuando
a nivel federal pues se estaba está esta
regulación que permitía el aborto en la
mayoría de estados aunque a pesar de
esta oposición que ya conocíamos de los
estados del sur y varios estados que
incluso texas estaban tratando de
encontrarle una salida a esta legalidad
del aborto pues ahora tendrán entonces
la libertad estos estados
pues legislar en cuanto al aborto y ser
ellos mismos los que tomen la decisión
también los republicanos están
preparando después de conocerse esta
decisión en el congreso una ley se sabe
y se pronostica que en las elecciones
legislativas de noviembre serán los
republicanos lo que los que toma el
control de la cámara baja de la cámara
de representantes- ellos tendrán
entonces en la mayoría en el senado en
la cámara de representantes-
posiblemente a partir de ahí tendrán
esta libertad para promulgar y para
avanzar con esta ley anti aborto no
solamente quieren tener el respaldo de
la corte suprema de justicia sino
también en el senado impulsando una ley
antiaborto esto tendrá obviamente pues
grandes repercusiones en temas de
natalidad en temas de salud de la mujer
y en muchos otros temas más cristóbal le
pregunta a las implicaciones inmediatas
para la aplicación de este fallo
[Música]
si se calcula que cerca de 25 estados
van a restringir aún más pues la
posibilidad que tengan a las mujeres de
abortar esto generará obviamente lo que
ya muchos analistas han discutido en el
pasado una migración de cara al aborto
es decir muchas personas muchas mujeres
que en sus estados no pueden abortar
pues llevarán a tener que ahorrar [__]
su carro y viajar de cualquier modo a un
estado que sí lo permita o como se ha
reportado en algunos casos usar clínicas
clandestinas esto pues pone en riesgo la
salud de la mujer la salud reproductiva
y pues también
es muchos analistas cuestionan también
que pues se está prohibiendo se está
limitando el derecho al aborto en la
mujer acá en eeuu pero también se está
limitando la posibilidad de que las
mujeres y las familias puedan criar a
sus hijos con necesidades básicas es
decir con todo este tema de la inflación
con todo este tema y más económico que
pasa eeuu por muchos temas y lo costoso
que es la vida precisamente después de
la pandemia pues muchos activistas que
apoyan el aborto dicen bueno no
solamente están restringiendo el aborto
pero por otro lado no están dando
herramientas para poder que los niños
crezcan con las necesidades básicas
resueltas así que pues sin duda será ese
un tema de emigración de cara al aborto
entre estados y pues hay muchos
programas sociales que van a tener que
empezar a desarrollarse para poder pues
ofrecer necesidades básicas a los niños
a las familias que no van a poder tomar
esta decisión de tener un hijo si
cristian incluso ya pues la sociedad
estadounidense se está pronunciando
digamos en esas protestas que vemos a
sus espaldas que usted se encuentra ahí
a las afueras de esta corte suprema de
eeuu del tribunal supremo de eeuu o
protestas a favor y en contra de esta
decisión es sin duda histórica que ha
finalmente pues afecta y atenta a los
derechos reproductivos de las mujeres
pues una decisión que ya tomó entonces
este supremo estadounidense que esto da
muchísimas gracias como siempre por toda
la información desde washington disip